The Pygmalion effect is the phenomenon
whereby higher expectations lead to
higher performance. It can be best
understood by a circle where our beliefs
about another person's abilities
influence our actions toward the other
person. This action has an impact on the other's beliefs about themselves. The
beliefs about themselves cause the
others actions toward us, which again
reinforce our beliefs about that person.
And so on and on and on. Let's look at an
example and start with your beliefs.
Imagine you are the coach of a
basketball team and you observe your
team on the first day: Chris and Joe are
new members of your team. Chris reminds
you of a famous player. Joe reminds you
of an annoying boy from your high school
years. Unconsciously you decide what to
expect of each one of them. Your beliefs
influence your actions: when Chris enters
the court you are happy to see him. When
he plays you push him to do better,
practice harder, stay an extra hour. If he
makes a mistake you explained to him how
to improve. When Joe comes in you hardly
notice him. You're glad to see him score
but you don't give him much feedback and
don't invest extra time in his training.
When Joe does a mistake
you are a little annoyed.
Your actions impact their beliefs about
themselves: Chris feels you appreciate
him and he appreciates you in return. He
believes in his own success. Joe feels
you have little patience and
appreciation for him he does not believe
in his own success. Their beliefs about
themselves causes their actions toward
you: Chris finds more and more joy and
playing and he never misses a training
session. During the games, he gives a
hundred percent all the time. Joe finds
less joy in playing than before and
doesn't give his full effort in the
games. He starts to miss the training
sessions sometimes. Which reinforces your
beliefs about them: you see how Chris
enjoys playing, how he trains hard and
shows a fast increase in his performance.
Joe seems not to be very motivated, his
skills don't increase as much and he
starts to show up less. You knew it right
away. Thank God your instincts were right!
The Pygmalion effect is also known as
the Rosenthal experiment named after a
research of Robert Rosenthal at Harvard.
In a first study, he challenged test
subjects to coach rats through a maze.
Half the group were told their rats were
extremely intelligent and specifically
trained, the other half were told that
their rats were dumb. In fact the rats
were all the same.
During the experiment however the "smart"
rats performed well better than the "dumb"
ones.
This showed how the expectations of the
coaches influenced even the performance
of rats.
Rosenthal then did the Pygmalion in
school study together with Lenore
Jacobson: at the beginning of the school
year a group of elementary school
teachers were told that some of their
new pupils had extraordinary talent and
potential. This information which was
completely made up was given about
random average students in each class.
All students had done the IQ test in
advance. By the end of the year the
students that were described as more
talented had significantly increased
their performance in the IQ tests
compared to the rest of the class. Robert
Rosenthal concluded: "When we expect
certain behaviors of others we are
likely to act in ways that make the
expected behavior more likely to occur."
what do you think about this theory? And
if you believe it is there a way to
prevent ourselves from being shaped by
others in a negative way? If you like
this video and the way we explain the
subject subscribe to our channel. We try
to explain complex subjects and simple
language and cartoons to support
students all around the world in their
learning. If you want to support us you
can go to www.patreon.com/sprouts and
donate, just $1 from many fans makes a
big difference!